The Joe Rogan experience,
there's a blog I read about Finn
privilege just to sit there.
That's another thing.
That's another way of saying fat shaming.
The other side of saying fat shaming is
that being thin you were enjoying thin
privilege and that by
creating success and all that,
not just dating success but
the way people dress you in,
the way you move around in society
that you enjoy thin privilege and what
they're trying to do is compare being
in shape with being a white male like
white male privilege is white.
Male privilege is almost shameful.
You know,
it's almost shameful to have this white
male privilege while people are stuck.
It's,
it makes you feel,
uh,
like the,
the,
like if someone talks
about white male privilege,
what do you think of,
you think of someone being
aloof to the concerns of,
of Brown people and poor people and racism
and also allude to the fact that they
got super lucky.
They got this lucky roll the dice and
were born in this way that allows them to
be.
I mean,
if you think about white males thinking
about white males and you think about
wealth,
majority of the like super
wealthy people are white males.
The majority of the people
that are in positions of power,
whether it's presidents,
mayor,
white males,
so that white male being a white male
and have that privilege is almost like
being in a pig.
It's like being the man so thin privilege.
They've figured out a way to
make being fin being a pig.
You've got to knock
willpower of that list.
There is no lack of willpower and fat
people willpower's a finite resource.
You have so much against.
We prove this beyond a doubt.
What do you mean willpower?
There's a whole book about this now,
and I'm forgetting the name of the author,
but they actually show that there's
so many decisions you can make.
I wrote about this a while back.
There's decision making fatigue and
there's x amount of willpower and you can
apply that will power to change the world.
Or you can apply that willpower to say
no to the bowl of chips in front of you.
Right?
And if you're a fat person and
your energy reserves are low,
and I say this from personal experience,
the amount of willpower it takes to get
up off the couch and walk across the
street and do whatever you're going to do,
it requires a hell of a lot more weird,
more willpower than you would think it
would as a healthy person because your
cells aren't working,
you don't have the energy,
and yet you get up and you do it in
every step you take is sapping your
willpower in a way a
healthy person doesn't have.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Saying that even though willpower is
sort of an individual characteristic and
some people have it,
some people don't.
With fat people,
it's almost like a catch 22 because
although they need it to drop away,
they're not gonna have it because
they needed to just move around.
Their energy levels are lower so they
have less willpower and they're using the
willpower to do simple things that
are effortless for you and it's not
effortless for a fat person.
That is such an interesting point and
one that I really didn't consider.
That's a very unique point because I,
I never really considered
that fat people like,
it's almost like they
can't help themselves.
It's almost like they're,
we'll or it's so much more difficult for
them to pass on shitty food than it is
a regular person.
Well,
think of it like this.
If you're a regular person
that's been privileged.
What branch of the military army?
How long were you in for?
Three.
Three years?
Well,
six years total.
What year was this?
80 two to 85 and then reserves
from 85 to eight years.
Let's you BA boom.
You out a wig.
That's just real.
Yo.
Did you get anything out
of being in the military?
Yeah,
discipline.
Yeah.
Just,
you know,
just again,
just being,
being responsible response ability,
the ability to respond.
Yeah.
People that have gone through that,
it's very interesting to see.
I had a friend who was a real lazy and
Kinda shiftless and never got anything
done and then went away,
went to bootcamp,
came back and this motherfucker
always folded his napkin after that.
Sat Up Straight and got
shit done and I was like,
wow.
They turned this dude around
like they're really did.
I wouldn't recommend it today because
joining today have a high likelihood of
either being forced to assassinate
someone for the government or finding
yourself in a position where you really
wouldn't want to be and people are
shooting out you that don't like
Americans and unless it's your calling,
I wouldn't really recommend it.
But goddamn,
for some people it
really is a game changer.
I agree.
Yeah.
And not all.
Not everyone can make it through it.
It's.
But the,
a lot of guys that kind of washed
out during that whole basic training.
What made you join College
Fund for Art School?
Really?
Will you pretty convinced that we weren't
going to go to war during those times
completely.
I was like,
war,
you know,
I didn't,
I just didn't believe it.
And then uh,
I got,
I got appointed to go,
I got a long process,
but basically it got handed a,
an opportunity to go to west point by
going to the preparatory school for a year
and uh,
got to the end when I finally got
my appointment to go to west point,
they said basically you have to forfeit
your army college fund to go to art
school.
And I didn't really go into
be a career military person.
I kind of went into get college
fund so I can go pursue the arts,
but,
you know,
but you're being,
again,
I was being my behavior as being
ready to forest as far as my,
the way I was excelling
as an in the military.
Um,
so it was very tempting to go,
I can be an officer,
let's do that.
And then you get,
you know,
it got to that moment where I had to,
like,
I had to make that
decision in that moment.
You have basically I had like three
hours to check the yes box that accept my
appointment or check
the no box and you know,
go back into the regular army.
And they go back to them,
go to art school and I chose,
I chose art school.
Alright.
And I,
if I had not done that,
I would have provided I
made it through west point,
which is not a guarantee.
If I'd have made it through west point,
I would have been in the first
Gulf war as a lieutenant.
Wow.
That's fucking crazy.
Well,
it also begs the question,
all of this stuff begs the question like,
first of all,
everyone's favorite argument is if you
have nothing to hide then what are you
worried about?
And it's not that.
What it is is first of all,
why do you need so much
information and what?
What have you done that have
made so many people so angry?
They have to check everyone's email.
Like what is the actual cause of
all this that never gets addressed.
Like whenever we're talking about how
this group hates us of that group hates us
and this group is playing.
Why?
What did we do?
I want to go with what you said that
the if you have nothing to hide,
because I was just.
I was trying to get a show up before
I came here and I failed miserably,
but one of the things I
was going to talk about,
did you see that story?
The lawsuit filed from that incident in
New Mexico with the driver who didn't do
the full stop leaving Walmart.
You saw it,
right?
Right.
So.
So the police pulled them over for,
for California,
stopping the stop sign.
Decide that he looks like he's
clenching his buttocks in a weird way,
and this is the part I love most to a
judge and says to the judge while this guy
is sitting on the side of the road,
he's clenching his buttocks.
In a weird way.
I think we have somebody trying to
hide drugs in there and the judge goes,
I guess judging from the story,
yeah,
that would be probable cause.
So they take this guy to a doctor who
refuses to do with the police officers
asked.
So they've got to go to another doctor.
Fourteen hours of anal cavity searches,
enemas.
They sedated him and did a colonoscopy.
They examined his stuff
right in front of him.
Fourteen hours,
found nothing.
X rayed him multiple times,
found nothing,
and then apparently send them a
$6,000 bill for the procedure.
So when you say,
what have you got to hide if any,
you.
Unless you're Heidi,
that's what can happen to you if.
And not just that.
What I love is the police
department spokesman said,
we didn't do anything wrong.
This is policy,
and we had a judge sign off on it.
So when you say,
if you have nothing to hide,
what do you care?
This guy had nothing to hide
and that happened to him.
Clearly did because he was away.
I know,
but now now that story's
true and the lawsuit,
claims witnesses and all this kind of
stuff and the police officers think
nothing was wrong there.
That's what happens to you when you get
rid of these protections that keep you
from being searched willy
nilly or anything like that.
But after a story like that,
everyone in the ward was going
to be stopped by the police.
Who's going to clean this
bathroom a weird way.
It's just the theater of the stories,
like
people that are bought freaks
and that's what they're into.
They're into cops checking them
out and treasures up there,
put secrets up there too.
I didn't mean to take
the conversation though.
It's a great direction.
It's hilarious.
It's.
Well,
it's fucked up that if you search,
someone's asked for 14 hours
and there's nothing up there.
That guy should be able to
search your house for 28.
That should be the rule.
You should be able to throw
firecrackers in there.
And come on,
man.
He checked his ass for no reason.
Like you owe him something.
What bothers me about that is that there's
no penalty that actually affects the
people who did this.
In other words,
if this guy wins is big
lawsuit against them,
that's the taxpayers who
are going to pay that.
The people who did it don't suffer at all.